practice gives you ultimate Freedom the
more you practice the better you get at
something the more skilled you are at it
the more information you have the more
it actually allows you to play more have
more fun be more flexible and have
ultimately more freedom this is
something I struggled with a lot in the
early days of my speaking career I was
asked to speak at a bunch of events and
I used to be so worried about
disappointing people that I would
memorize my entire speech and just
memorize my speech to the point where
word for word it would be the exact same
thing every time and I thought that was
good I thought that's what you're
supposed to do obviously yes practice
makes perfect keep going keep practicing
keep doing it what ended up happening
was yes I delivered the same speech each
time but I think the worst thing you can
do as a speaker is just give the exact
same speech every time your job if
you're a speaker is to give your
audience a fantastic experience and so
it's knowing who's in the audience don't
assume it's the same people every single
time so you have to be able to know so
much about your subject that then you
can have your framework that you operate
in but then give a lot more value to
People by making it custom to them want
to S get a mentor hey it's Nina car
Michael and we made these videos it's
probably because you're the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you need
that Porche by surround yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best my husband Evan carmichel
and learned the simple step to achieve
ultimate Freedom
[Music]
enjoy we did a session of Movie Makers
around uh signature talk it was one of
the most voted topics was how do I give
my signature talk and I think having one
signature talk is actually not great I
think you should be able
to be able to speak to the audience
every time your job if you're a speaker
is to give your audience a fantastic
experience and so it's knowing who's in
the audience don't assume it's the same
people every single time right so you
have to be able to know so much about
your subject that then you can have your
framework that you operate in but then
give a lot more value to People by
making it custom to them so now whenever
I'm doing a speaking gig I'm always
asking okay tell me about the audience
tell me who's here tell me why people
are setting up what what are people here
for both in terms of the information
they're hoping to get uh as well as
their background and their interests and
their concerns and what they struggle
with and of course there's genuine human
struggles that everybody goes through
but why are people here at this
conference and so here's my process
right now when I'm doing a a speech or
talk they're going to have me coming
they're going to talk about belever or
entrepreneurship or YouTube it's going
to be some set themes you're not having
me come to talk about my apple strudel
recipe because I don't have one right
I'm coming in talk about things that are
inside my domain perfect and I could
easily just get up on stage and talk but
I want to know who's in the audience so
before going I'll ask them tell me about
the people who are going to be here and
then I'll frame my speech around a
couple of key ideas that I think would
be valuable to that audience still
sitting within kind of the my usual
domain perfect I'll practice it I'll
practice giving a speech I'll practice
the points at at home I'll practice I'll
practice talking to my dog I'll practice
on the airplane on the way over I'll
practice to kind of get a sense of the
stories that I want to tell that I think
will be the right fit but then the day
before and the day of I like to be there
a little early to to talk to people to
one makes me feel a little more
comfortable um being able to connect to
people in the audience so it's not just
people I don't know but I've had a few
conversation with people but two in
feeling the vibe out of the event I'll
often end up switching up part of my
talk again to make it as customizable as
possible to the people that I'm talking
to and this isn't just a speaking thing
guys this is any interaction you're
doing you're trying to sell your product
you're trying to sell your service
you're on a call with somebody who could
use your product or service hire you as
a coach Etc you have to customize your
pitch customize your talk for them not
just give the same thing every single
time you're talking to somebody you have
to know what makes them tick know why
they're talking to you what their their
deep desires and fears are and address
those things so that you can close the
sale right it's the same thing I'm just
giving an example through
speaking so it's being willing to
deviate from your talk
to actually give more
value and I think again the worst thing
you can do as a speaker is just give get
on stage you can give the same talk
every single time that's what I used to
think was the way to go but this is
actually lot more valuable because you
can inspire people but one it becomes
boring for you to get up and just do the
same thing over and over and over again
and two if you can customize it to
actually address the thing that they are
specifically concerned about you're
going to have a bigger impact why you
there you're there to touch people
you're there to move
people to a positive direction right
again whether you're whether you're
speaking or you're just talking to
somebody on the phone a potential client
why are you working with them yes
they're going to pay you but why you
want them to get a result you want them
to move you want them to make a change
you want to solve a problem for them and
so the more you can actually connect to
what they're struggling with the easier
it is for you to to close a sale and
have the impact that you're trying to
have so it's a lot more fun it's a lot
more impactful a lot more meaningful and
so that's my usual process now why are
people here I'll prepare
a version of my speech to address those
people and then it always changes up the
day of because I met somebody in the
lobby who inspired me or I met somebody
on the airplane the day before who
shifted my thinking a little bit and
gives me an extra story to tell and when
you're so prepared and you know your
stuff so much it's easy to add those
things in when you don't really know
you're kind of all over the
place so it's being overly prepared and
then the day of being willing to be
flexible it's that like rigidity of
practice and practice and practice and
knowing what you're doing so much that
allows you to play when you show up it's
the if you you know go into sports you
practice your free throw so much you
practice your penalty shots so much you
practice you practice so much that
allows you to be a lot more flexible and
play when it comes to game time let me
share another quick example from the
opposite side where I was interviewing
somebody so instead of being the person
on stage speaking I'm interviewing
somebody and I recently had Tony Robbins
on the channel and it's the third time
it came on the channel the first two
interviews we did had 3 million views on
them combined which is amazing and he's
coming back for the third time talk
about his new book and I'm always
nervous before a big interview and this
is probably the least nervous I've been
because it's the third time on but I was
still nervous going in and so I'm
preparing I'm preparing and preparing
and preparing I'm trying to find a
thread that I care about I don't want to
just ask the same questions everybody
else has asked I don't want to just use
the questions that his PR agency sent
over cuz he's going to answer those
questions on every other show I want it
to be different and unique and fun and
special and so I prepared I know I've
got uh half an hour with him uh I know
he likes to go long in his story so you
don't get that many questions in so I
need to I need to really be careful of
what I'm going to say and make this time
count it'd be easy just to show up and
ask okay why did you write this book
what does it mean to you what do you
hope people get from it what was your
favorite part about it and then then
half an hour is done and you haven't
really asked anything super
meaningful so I'm
preparing and I wrote down on a notepad
file that I had opened when I was
talking to him you know four questions
five questions that I wanted to ask and
I practiced how I would ask him I
practice you know what what I was going
to say and then I practiced it so much
that come game time come Showtime here
we go Tony's coming on let's let's do
our
one-on-one I was able to actually be
present and listen to what it was saying
say and and play ball with him right to
to throw and catch with him instead of
just going to the questions when you
have't prepared and you're really
insecure you just go to the questions
you just go okay here's what I said okay
here and just ask the question where the
best interviews are when you can throw
and catch right where they say something
and you take that a little bit deeper as
opposed to just moving on to the next
question cuz I've watched a lot of
interviews and in the work that I do and
one of the things that I find most
frustrating is the person says something
amazing and you want them to it's like
okay ask a follow-up question and
instead of asking a follow-up question
they just go to the next question
because the interviewer it was never
even listening to what the interviewee
was saying they're just so worried about
getting the next question in that that's
that's all they're thinking about and so
like uhhuh uh-huh okay great and then
tell me about this next question without
going deeper into the conversation so I
didn't want to be that kind of
interviewer even I get it cuz you're
nervous
you're not fully prepared you're worried
about the
questions so one example with Tony he
was talking about a recent Health scare
that he had and that his career would be
over the doctor said your career is
over and in my head I was thinking about
some of the other stuff I knew about
Tony Robbins and so I asked him how many
times have you been told that your
career is
over it was off script right it wasn't
something his team prepared it wasn't
something Tony's maybe been
and I asked him how many times have you
been told that your career has been over
because I remember uh you know he had
this um tumor that made him grow crazy
quickly and and people said his life
would be over remember he burned out his
voice box and his doctors told him he'd
never speak on stage again and now this
injury that happened to him he wasn't
going to be able to go and do his event
so he's been told consistently that his
career would be
over and yet he still gets up and he
finds a way and he does it right one of
the things that we love about his
ability to follow through and stay
consistent and so in the over
preparation and knowing his story and
also knowing that I had questions to
fall back on in case there was a lull in
the conversation it allows the play it
allows the freedom it allows you to
adjust to the situation which then
creates a much better experience so
whether you're speaking whether you're
interviewing whether you're coaching
whether you're mentoring whether you're
on a sales call you need to know your
script you need to know what you're
going to say you need to understand your
customer and who you're talking to you
need to know all that and over prepare
but
then understand that the greatest asset
that you have is not in rehearsing again
the script is that you have the ability
to be free now that you can play cuz
you've done all the drills and now you
need to have the back and forth it's
it's throwing and catching I'm going to
throw the ball to you you're going to
catch it you're going to throw the ball
back to me it's not just throwing where
a lot of times the biggest mistake is
that you're just throwing you're just
throwing another one and another one and
here's my other line here's my next
question here's my next pitch throw
throw throw throw throw and the person
might be saying uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh but
there's no receiving and them throwing
the ball back to you that's the best
part in any interaction if you have a
goal to get them to move forward to make
a change in your life to to sign you up
to hire you to work with you so you can
make that impact that you're trying to
make there has to be that back and forth
and the more prepared you are the easier
it is to then have the freedom to play
rule number two find your own balance
most people suck at creating work life
balance or Harmony because you're
constantly comparing what you're doing
to other people's schedules of all the
things that you need to figure out in
life what balance means to you is among
the most important Jeff Bezos jokes
about optimizing his toothbrushing
routine because he's trying to Max
maximized his efficiency while Warren
Buffett reads for 5 to 6 hours every day
you can't do both and you need to stop
comparing yourself to someone who you're
not it's crazy how much balance and
scheduling comes up I think most people
are lost I think I think again the
biggest problem is you're just comparing
yourself to other people and then you
don't know where to stand you don't know
what rock to stand on and so you feel
like you're pulled in a thousand
different directions when I went on my
tour this year and I'm sure it's going
to come up on the next one again people
kept asking that what does balance mean
to you how do I find balance in my life
and and I used to joke one of the
funniest jokes that I told and I'm not
that funny so this is this is one of the
funny moments um was I was talking about
the Rock and The Rock has his routine
where he's working out for four hours a
day he has to work out for 4 hours a day
and so when he's doing his movies he
wakes up 5 hours before he has to be on
set and he'll work out for his 4 hours
and he'll do two times cardio and two
times weights and then go to the you
know go to his trailer shower and then
head head out to the movies and he's
only sleeping four to five hours at
night when he's on set I think that's
crazy but I don't look like the Rock and
that's when people would laugh cuz I
don't look like the rock but it's true
people will try to take on the Rock
schedule but you have other
priorities what the Rock values isn't
the same thing as you value there may be
some overlap and some similarities and
there's nothing wrong with trying on the
hat there's nothing wrong with
attempting to do it there's nothing
wrong with seeing how it fits right to
get pieces to say hey I'm going to try
meditating I'm going to try working out
I'm going to try making a video I'm
going to try morning Pages I'm going to
awesome great yes but then to judge
yourself to say well I'm not able to
stay consistent on that it's not what
you should be doing because you want to
work out 4 hours a day and you want to
read 5 hours a day like Warren Buffett
and you want to optimize your toothbrush
routine like Jeff Bezos and you want to
do all these different things but it's
too many hours in a day what you have to
figure out is how does balance look like
for you and then not be ashamed to go
off and live it when everybody else
thinks you're nuts so how do you do it
I'm going to give you a three-step
process that I think will help step
number one is start to figure out what
is balanced Harmony look like for you
whatever you want to call it sit down
take some time book off half the day
this is worth it this is worth it if
it's a Saturday afternoon or Sunday
morning whenever you are the most free
and creative find a space that you love
whether it's walking out of nature or or
you know your desk at home or a coffee
shop Library something where you can
just be by yourself not have
distractions and really just ask
yourself what does a balanced life look
like for you what does harmony look like
for you because you don't want to spend
all day at work you don't and you don't
want to spend all day with your family
either you don't you don't want to spend
all day doing anything but what's that
ratio look like you don't want to spend
all day sleeping what's that ratio
between how much time sleeping how much
time with your family how much time on
your hobbies how much time with your
friends how much time at work what does
that ratio look like for you and you may
get a weird duck answer like it may not
fit into the society's Norms that's okay
right it starts with you understanding
understanding this is what I need for my
life having Clarity and having certainty
around it so that when other people
judge you for your crazy schedule say
this is what I need this is what I need
remember the people who are judging you
are all insecure about their own life
and their own schedule too so don't
worry about it go live your life spend
the half day maybe do it right now if
you have some ideas already what does
balance or Harmony look like for you
number two is map your actions to your
Ambitions okay great now that you've set
out what a what a perfectly Balanced
Life looks like for you what you got to
do it
you're show me your calendar where
you're actually doing it I live my life
by different days so Monday's my
mentoring day Tuesday is my YouTube day
Wednesday is my project day Thursday's
my public facing day Friday is my CEO
day Saturday is fun day with the family
and Sunday is family admin day Costco
and shopping and groceries and laundry
and all that stuff right and that's how
most of the time I live my life when I'm
on tour when I'm uh doing trips or
something speaking then it gets a little
bit more chaotic but then it returns
back to normal because because that's
what balance Harmony looks like for me
that may be crazy for you that may be
crazy for you if you look at my
Thursdays it's back to back to back
meetings I might have I might have 10 or
15 meetings back to back to back to back
to back with like 2 three 4 minute
breaks in between that's it all day long
from 9:00 in the morning until sometimes
11:00 at night I love it it's great and
then on on Wednesday look at my calendar
it's open
nothing white space to work on whatever
I want to work on cuz if I'm doing my
book or I'm working working on my course
or I'm doing some creative work I like
having the entire day wide open for me
to do it so I don't book meetings on a
on a Wednesday I don't talk to my team
on a Wednesday I don't make videos on a
Wednesday I do my project work on a
Wednesday right it's what I love doing
and so that works for me that may be the
worst thing of all time for you awesome
but my actions mapped to my ambitions if
I set out what does balance look like
for me this is it I'm living it just
like Saturday is funay don't message me
on a Saturday you're not going to get a
response I'm spending the day with my
wife I'm planning surprises for her I'm
taking to a new restaurant we're
planning some kind of activities to do
together so we do on Saturdays right
that's my version of balance but at the
same time during the week my wife and I
we work together so I see her a lot but
uh we don't start hanging out at night
until
8:00 right that may seem crazy for you
but then we have all of Saturday
completely shut down to work on things
together fun things and then Sunday the
whole day to do what is actually family
work right that works for us it works
for me it works for her it works for us
it maybe the worst thing of all time for
you maybe you do want to spend 3 hours a
day cuddling with your husband or wife
awesome put it in I'm not judging you
put it in go do it if that's what leads
you to be happy Balan and you bring the
best of you everywhere you go then you
do it you created your version of
balance now you need to map your actions
to your Ambitions and put it in your
calendar and stick to it and then set
number three is follow the Quincy Jones
rule Quincy Jones the legendary music
producer once said not one ounce of my
selfworth comes from your opinion of me
and I really love that cuz I think so
often we play small based off of other
people's opinions and expectations of
you all these other people with low
standards who hate their lives are
judging you and you now live your life
by their low standards somebody who
hates their life right they're just on
the edge of depression or maybe they're
already there and they're judging you
and these are the people whose opinions
you care so much about not one ounce of
my selfworth comes from your opinion of
me that doesn't have to be something you
say out loud to them that might cause
some problems but in your own head in
your own head right their opinion
doesn't mean anything to you if somebody
looks at your calendar and you're
cuddling your husband and wife for 3
hours a day and that's what you need
awesome embrace it this is who I am I'm
crushing it what are you doing are you
happy with your life right follow the
Quincy Jones room also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number three raise your
environment your environment has been
perfectly created to keep you exactly
where you are everything around you your
friends your family the media you
consume all keeps you exactly where you
are if you want to raise your standards
and raise the quality of your life it
starts with raising your environment so
here's a story I haven't told in a while
when I was building up my YouTube
channel and I closed my first multi-year
deal with a big brand it was with a CEO
high-powered CEO one of the largest
companies in the world especially in The
Entrepreneur Space and it was going to
be me and him on my channel every month
answering questions from you guys from
the audience we did a live stream every
month and it wasn't me interviewing him
or him interviewing me was both of us
talking about a certain topic and then
taking questions and I remember driving
with my dad he was getting a new car and
we had this long drive out for whatever
reason the place where we wanted to buy
the car was super far away and so it
gave us this chance to talk in a car and
I just told him about this new deal that
I had signed I remember him asking me
Evan what gives you the confidence to
feel like you're on the same level as
this guy and he didn't mean it in a in a
negative way it was it was in a more
ostri way he like man look at where
you've come from because my family is
very humble like you have to be very
humble you have to appreciate what
you've got and so how am I now how do I
see myself on the same stage as as high
powerered CEO being his equal answering
questions and the question took me ab
and I thought you know what he's right I
mean if this was Evan of 5 years prior I
would have felt not worthy I would have
felt like I couldn't do it I would have
felt like this is too big an opportunity
for me like I couldn't be the guy to do
it so what changed 5 years ago to where
I was at that point it was my content it
was my channel it was all the videos
that I'm I'm putting up cuz in my head
it was a big deal and that this is the
largest deal I had signed for 3 years
but more that I'm around Oprah every day
and and Dan Peña every day and Kanye
West every day and all these people
every day and so I feel like I'm with
them and and so this CEO deal wasn't
that huge a deal because I had changed
my environment right i' had raised the
stakes in my environment and that raises
your standards and so I realized man
this is crazy how important my channel
is to myself at least to my own growth
if it's not to you at least to my own
growth because you often can't see it on
a daily basis I could not pinpoint the
one video I uploaded or the one day that
I felt this is it it's happened but if I
look back over a 5year period a oneyear
period a six-month period even a 3-month
period think about who you were three
months ago if you're investing in
yourself by watching these videos or
reading books or anything else if you're
investing in yourself even just look
three months back and think have I grown
how much have you grown in the past 3
months
you may not see it on a daily basis but
with months and then more months and
then more months and then years if you
keep on the path you'll see some
tremendous results mean you not even
recognize the person who you used to be
and that's why it's so important that
you raise your environment I'm going to
give you three ways that you can
actually do it step number one is chart
your start and this is the importance of
having a morning routine this is what
most people don't get everybody wakes up
the same I wake up the same Dan Peña
wakes up the same Bill Gates wakes up
the same Oprah everybody wakes up the
same the difference is in the habits
that set them up for Success the
difference is that most of America wakes
up like an accident and you pull out
your phone and you're just responding to
the emergencies other people's
emergencies other people's demands for
your time that's what most people do you
wake up like an accident more important
is to chart your start having a morning
routine that sets you up for Success
what is the thing that makes you sore
what is the thing that makes you feel
bold confident alive and then put that
into your morning routine every single
day if you woke up and did the thing
with in tension that made you feel bold
confident Unstoppable alive you did that
every day I guarantee you a year from
now you're going to look back and be a
totally different person chart your
start with your morning routine step
number two is build your Batcave I'm a
big believer in that the physical
environment matters too so it's not just
about the habits and routines it's the
physical environment it's it's it's what
you wear I feel like Batman putting this
on it's the expression that you have
it's the physical environment that you
have it's what's on the background of
your cell phone and your screen right
all of these things make me feel feel
like a superstar it's been designed with
intention do it for yourself this office
might not be for you you might walk in
here and say that sucks I hate all of it
great it's not your office people often
write to me though and say hey can we
can I buy the pictures that are behind
you well they're not for sale but like
this is me when I'm eight or nine with
my parents you want that picture hanging
on your wall you like build the thing
that gets you feeling bold confident
Unstoppable alive these people all mean
something to me the Doritos bag means
something to to me the the awards here
mean something to me even standing up at
a standing desk all of it's been
designed I built my Batcave you're
superhero 2 build your Batcave so that
when you walk into your office when you
go into the environment that you can't
control it's inspiring it's uplifting it
reminds you of who you want to be and
step number three is to use the words
tell me I suck this is one of the
greatest lessons that I learned in my
life is whenever I'm going to talk to
somebody who I think can teach me
there's somebody who I I I'm going to
meet face to face or on the phone or
email that I think can help me in some
way I'll start by saying tell me why I
suck tell me why I suck tell me why I'm
the
worst and the answer that always comes
back is well you don't suck but if you
did these three things you'll get better
so why lead with the tell me I suck it's
not because I'm I'm I like pain it's
because it gives permission to that
person to be honest because most people
can't handle the truth and so when
there's advice coming to you most people
will hedge it they'll hedge the truth
they'll tell you a really soft version
of it because they don't want to hurt
you they don't want to offend you they
don't want your feelings to be bruised
and so when you lead with tell me I suck
what it does is gives them permission to
be honest because the only way you grow
is through the honest feedback and so
the next time you meet somebody who can
help you with something whether it's
your YouTube channel your speaking
career your next book you're giving them
your manuscript your paintain whatever
idea you have next tell them tell me why
I suck tell me why this is the worst
thing of all time let me know be honest
and that permission for them to be
honest will give you the truth that you
need to get better rule number four get
focused if you are not focused on your
goals you either don't want them or you
are afraid of them you might just not
want to do them you might be in the
wrong thing you might have picked the
wrong goals for the wrong reasons or
you're afraid of your goals you're
afraid of failing you're afraid of it
not working out and what that means
either way the answer is action if you
don't love it move on immediately and if
you're afraid of it move into it
immediately focused action is always the
answer so one of the entrepreneurs that
I've invested into his name is Alex he
helps me run Toronto dance salsa which
is the largest salsa dance school in
Canada maybe North America and we're
sitting down reviewing his goals and
reviewing his habits and making sure
that you know what he said he was going
to do matches to him accomplishing his
goals and there were a couple things
that were big things on the list that he
had to get done and he was afraid of
making a mistake so for example we're
trying to going to create the interior
of the studio and make a wall that
speaks to the purpose of the company
speaks to the the mission the vision
what we're trying to accomplish and we
want to have something beautiful that
people want to take their pictures on
and he's so afraid of getting it right
he's so afraid of doing the wrong thing
that he does nothing and every time he
opens up the file to look at what he
wants to do and different ideas he's
afraid he's going to make a mistake he's
afraid is going to invest time energy
dollars my money into something that
then when people show up say huh and it
doesn't work out he's so afraid to fail
that he doesn't take action which
becomes the biggest failure of all so
here was our solution procrastination
Power Hour said every day PPH put it
into your calendar for one hour this is
your PPH time the thing that you have
been procrastinated on right the thing
that serves the business if if you've
been procrastinated on it and you don't
like it and it doesn't serve the
business great get rid of it that's not
what we're talking about it's the things
that you're afraid of the things that
you don't want to make a mistake on that
you're just pushing aside because
there's all this busy work that comes in
because yes we have to respond to
customers and yes we got to do all the
work that goes into dayto day of running
the company but if you're so focused on
just the day-to-day and never focus on
the things that will actually help you
grow the bigger picture stuff then guess
what happens you never do the bigger
picture stuff especially if it's because
you're afraid then you have to take
action so we planned a daily
procrastination Power Hour that he puts
into his calendar and he looks at it
when he gets there he thinks what am I
procrastinating the most on and he's got
this list and he starts attacking it and
having that in his calendar is the thing
that actually started building momentum
for those big projects so I've got a
three-step process you can use to stay
more focused and get your work done
let's do it step number one is plan your
procrastination Power Hour you have to
put in your calendar if it's not in your
calendar it's not going to get done if
you're just hoping that one day you you
magically get yourself it's not going to
happen the things that you've been
procrastinated on the things that you
afraid to do the things that will
actually move the company forward that
you've been sitting on you have to put
in your calendar you've been
procrastinating it's it's not acceptable
anymore it's time to move on 1 hour
every day dedicated put put it in
procrastination power hour and then make
a list of all the things you've been
procrastinated on and that's the only
thing you're allowed to work on in that
hour don't check Facebook don't check
your Instagram don't be answering phone
calls no interviews maybe you take a
couple losses for your business that's
okay because you're focused on something
big that will catapult the company
forward plan your procrastination Power
Hour step number two is map your actions
to your ambition so your actions have to
map to your Ambitions what what you say
you want to do what you say you want to
accomplish these goals this Vision this
great big thing that you have that I
know you have cuz you're Purpose Driven
that's why you're watching this channel
you want to accomplish big things and
have a big impact on the world great
what you say you want are you doing the
steps look at your calendar pull it up
load it up take out your phone pause
this video and load it up and see what
are you doing the next week how you
going to spend the next seven days look
at the tasks that you've assigned for
yourself the meetings you're going to
have where you going to be blocking your
time what you're spending that valuable
time you have on do your actions map to
your Ambitions if you did the things
that you say are in your calendar for
the next week will that help you move
closer to your goals success is habits
success is what you consistently do you
are what you consistently do now what
happens in these one-off moments you
could watch a video get all amped up and
motivated and be on fire and work but
then you fall back to regular life
that's not going to move the needle for
your business it's what you do
consistently so every week is looking at
that calendar and saying if I did this
stuff if I did these tasks if I
accomplish these things I will move
closer to achieving the life that I want
and accomplishing the goals that I've
set for myself your actions have to map
to your Ambitions and set number three
is chart your start this is having a
powerful morning routine that sets you
up for success I go through five s's
every morning the most important one is
the third one which is sore where I want
to do the thing every day that makes me
sore that makes me feel like the work I
do matters that the thing that I do has
meaning and value because I could have
the greatest day of all time maybe I'm
meeting an entrepreneur and it's just it
fills me up knowing that I help them but
then I wake up tomorrow and it's like
I'm starting over every day it feels
like I'm starting over and so you need
that injection daily and ideally first
thing in the morning so whatever the
thing is for you if it's watching these
videos amazing I have one for you every
morning if it's a 254 series that I have
your own confidence or self-love or
motivational speakers all of that great
go sign up it's free you get it to your
inbox at 5:00 a.m. eastern I think every
morning if it's reading a book or
listening to a or doing an AC of service
and and buy the coffee for the person
behind you in line every day whatever
the thing is that makes you sore sore
like you're bold confident alive capable
of doing great things when you believe
in yourself that you can do something
amazing that's what I'm talking about
making that consistent and putting into
your morning routine cuz if you woke up
every morning and did the thing that
made you feel Unstoppable bold confident
man I guarantee you your life is going
to look dramatically different 6 months
12 months 18 months down the line you
won't even recognize the person who you
used to be but you have to demand it
from yourself by putting it into your
morning routine chart your start rule
number five the last one before our very
special bonus clip take action The Law
of Attraction definitely works most
people just get it wrong most people
only focus on the thinking part and not
the most important part which is the
action right Law of Attraction it's the
last five letters that matter a c t i o
a c t i o n six the last six it does
matter action action action thinking
about it alone is not enough so it's the
two parts you get an idea you want
something into your life you want to
manifest something amazing you want
success in your business you want a
happy relationship awesome you want to
speak on giant stages whatever the thing
is that you want in your life awesome
you have a vision board amazing just the
fact that you're thinking about it and
believing in it is already a big step
ahead of where most people are most
people live in a Negative Zone most
people feel like their life is hopeless
that they can't make a change that
they're stuck where they are and guess
what happens they stay exactly stuck
where they are right what you focus on
ends up becoming your reality so yes
you're going to focus on your new goal
your new habit the new thing that you
want into your life amazing you believe
that it's possible amazing you're
putting up a vision board with it on
your wall amazing you're researching and
watching videos like this every day
amazing that's great that's the first
starting point but nothing happens until
you take action nothing happens until
you take action thinking alone is not
enough again it puts you ahead of most
of the most of the world puts you way
ahead of them but you're still just
going to be this super smart super
ambitious person sitting at home not
achieving your goals you have to do
something I look at my YouTube channel
as an example uh my main Channel I want
to get to 10 million subscribers that's
my next goal right we hit one we hit two
I got to hit 10 uh at the rate that
we're growing it's not fast enough like
it's going to take me way too many years
to make it happen so I need to apply
more pressure against it so part of what
I look at every day now my morning
routine is I want to hit my goal I want
to get 10 million subscribers on my
YouTube channel right I want to be you
know one of the first uh thought leaders
experts business person to have 10
million subscribers on a YouTube channel
it's my next goal great writing that
down every day doesn't make sure that
it's going to happen what am I doing
right writing it down can lead to
thoughts that then lead to action but
what am I actually doing well I'll tell
you what I'm doing now one of the
biggest things I'm working on now big
new Initiative for my team is I've got
6,000 public videos on my main Channel
and I told my team this week I want to
go back and update all of the thumbnails
in all of the titles across all my
videos that's a lot of videos right
that's 6,000 videos imagine doing split
tests on all of those videos uh I asked
for 10 a day and so two key people on my
team are working together to come up
with what the title is going to be and
then the other ones doing the graphic
design to create the thumbnails maybe it
works the first time maybe it doesn't
and it's said big ambitious project if
you think about it we got 6,000 videos
10 videos a day you know in a year if we
did it for 10 videos every day we're
just over half of those videos assuming
that they all work out which they won't
so this is our test and if it works
awesome I might have that become
somebody's full-time job so that we can
do 20 split tests a day 40 split tests a
day 100 split tests a day I don't know
but it's happening to action right so it
starts with the idea if you have the
idea but you're not taking action you
won't get results if you just have the
action but you have no idea you're
running around with a chicken with your
head cut off you're you're going in
circles without any clear Direction most
people think too much and don't do
enough that's most people some people do
too much and don't think enough some
people need more planning but in general
most people are over planners and so
watching this video alone is not enough
it's a great start it might boost your
motivation it might give you an idea to
go off and try watching my content
watching Dan content alone is not enough
it's the essential first piece of the
ingredient it's it's essential
surrounding yourself with people who
build you up who make you believe who
give you ideas you can act on that allow
you to feel like your goals are are
possible that your dreams are within
reach is super important I do it every
day it's why I create all these channels
I think you should too you'll notice a
difference in how you think every single
day if you are creating content and
consuming content that builds you up but
then you you have to go take the Second
Step it's why after every video I have a
question the day or I have a three-point
Landing question because I want you to
take action you should you need to teach
yourself that after every video you
watch after every podcast you listen to
after every book that you read that
that's not enough you have to do
something about it I'd rather you watch
fewer videos read fewer books listen to
fewer podcasts consume less if you're
taking action on the ideas that come to
you because most people are just
professional consumers
and it's great that you're consuming
educational content because most people
are just consuming stupid content right
you hate your life so you go watch
Netflix all day when you get home for 5
hours and then go to sleep right you're
a professional consumer but you're
consuming uh wasteful content just
entertaining content so you've already
taken a step above right you're
consuming educational content that's the
next step you're consuming educational
content amazing but still that alone is
not enough what separates the people go
off and achieve their dreams from the
ones who just have things on a vision
board is that last step of taking action
so you're not allowed anymore your new
standards you're raising your standards
for yourself you are not allowed anymore
to watch a video to read a book to
listen to a podcast to consume anything
without taking some kind of immediate
action towards it immediate action
immediate action it may not be the big
thing if you want to hit a million
subscribers on your YouTube channel
great what's the immediate action film a
video today make an improvement to your
thumbnail today reach out for an
interview for someone today right
immediate action teach yourself that as
soon as you get an idea you do something
about it because that's the only thing
that you're missing the only thing that
you're missing is momentum if you're
watching this channel you believe in
your talent you know you're capable of
more you've got big goals big Ambitions
Big Dreams for yourself the only thing
you're missing is momentum so to
activate the Law of Attraction pay
attention to the last six letters action
and start doing something about
it
when did you decide that your dreams
shouldn't be big when did you decide
that you shouldn't tell anyone else
about your dreams until you own your
dreams and stop making yourself feel
small those dreams will never happen
never now this is something everybody
struggles with everybody myself Mel
everybody we're worried about playing a
bigger game we're worried about thinking
bigger for ourselves and we're worried
about telling other people because what
if it doesn't work out what if we don't
make naked what's that judgment going to
come how are they going to think about
us and so I think about my own story
what I'm trying to create the biggest
fight that I used to get into with my
agent Steve was he says Evan you need to
be a household name you need to be
famous like Steve I don't want to be
famous i i i equated famous to Ego if
you're famous and you're this big
egomaniac I didn't I don't want to be an
egomaniac it's not it's not about me
it's about spreading belief I don't I'm
nervous getting in front of the camera
even before filming this video I'm
nervous like I wanted to want it to do
well the lights come on I don't crave it
I don't crave attention I'm an introvert
I like just doing my thing Evan you need
to get famous why Steve why do I need to
get famous and for maybe two years we
fought over this cuz I kept equating
Fame with ego and I looked at the people
who were famous and like I don't want to
be like them and there's a lot that they
did that that bothered me and I I wanted
to do it a different way and that's the
key it's finding the different way to to
do it how does an introvert on a mission
become famous I don't know we're going
to go on this journey together and
hopefully find out what finally clicked
for me was him saying when you get
famous your mission will spread if you
start tying actions to Mission that's
how you get me to move for other people
might be hey I'll give you all this
money if you do this or you'll have the
fame or or credibility or have statues
built I don't need statues built of me
but as soon as you tie it to Mission and
service that gets me going so he said if
you actually want to fulfill your
mission if you say you want to spread
believe then you need to get famous
because the more people know about you
the more people will hear your message
and it finally it finally stuck like
okay I got to do it I don't know how to
do it I've never I've never tried to do
it I've I've always wanted to be behind
the spotlight and so now now this is
part of my mission I need to become a
household name and get famous so that
more people can believe in themselves if
I actually want to solve the world's
biggest problem then I need to be out
there doing it I need to believe in
myself more right if I'm trying to
spread believe I need to believe in
myself more too and so I think that's a
human condition that's part of what we
want to do you want to step outside your
comfort zone you want to serve humans
are built to serve we are we are built
to serve but service requires helping
other people and because we're afraid of
judgment you don't want to do it so
you've got your foot in the gas and the
break at the same time you want to help
people but you're worried about their
judgment so you don't do anything you
know you're capable of more you know
you're capable of more but you don't do
it because you're afraid and so I'm
going to give you a three-step process
that really helped me that's worked for
me that I hope can work for you too
because I want to see that genius you've
got inside you explode out into the
world step number one is believing that
you have Michael Jordan level Talent
this is something that I say a lot and
it's something that I I I believe in
myself as well I need to remind myself
of it that I have have Michael Jordan
level Talent at something you have
Michael Jordan level Talent at something
you are worthy you are talented you're a
genius you're amazing remember that and
just because you don't see it in where
you're at right now doesn't mean that
you can't become great there's a famous
quote that I'm probably going to botch
by Albert Einstein who's who's basically
saying that if you try to judge a fish
by its ability to climb a tree you think
it's an idiot and that's what most
people are doing they're fish trying to
be Force to climb a tree where you
should swim you can swim right you know
inside you that you have amazing talent
and it's just beli it in that a little
bit more but you can be Michael Jordan
at something step number two is I remind
myself of the Quincy Jones Rule and the
Quincy Jones rulle is one of my favorite
clips of all time on my channel is where
he said not one drop of my self worth
depends on your except on to me and
whenever I'm worried whenever I'm
thinking about how people see this or
judge me I remind myself of that the
Quincy Jones rule not one ounce of my
selfworth not one drop comes from your
acceptance of
me and and just having that as a
reminder when you're afraid when you're
about to make a video when you're about
to write your book when you're about to
get on stage you're about to tell
somebody about your idea when you're at
a networking event and somebody asks you
what you do and you and you feel small
and you want to play small just use it
in that moment remind yourself of the
Quincy Jones rule I'm going to speak my
truth and not one ounce of my self-worth
comes from your acceptance of me and
then step number three is the boom boom
boom test and that's that's where when
your heart's going boom boom boom right
your heart's going boom boom boom you're
scared you're nervous you're afraid you
have to do it it's a sign that you're
actually on the right path 98% of the
time right that 2% is when you're about
to jump out of an airplane and you don't
have a parachute okay great don't do
that that's crazy right don't don't be
stupid but most of the things you're
afraid of is not actually physical harm
we don't live in a society where you're
constantly in danger right if it's
physical harm and danger okay maybe you
want to take the safer route but most of
the things we're afraid of are our
judgment our people's opinions our
expectations that's what you're really
afraid of and so when you're about to do
something and your heart's going like
this or when you're thinking of
something or somebody suggest something
to you hey what do you think about this
and your heart's going like this that's
a sign to go that's not a sign to think
that's not a sign to think when your
heart is going boom boom boom boom the
boom boom boom test is not a time to
think because you're going to think your
way down from the big idea your brain is
designed to protect you it understands
the world that currently exists so it's
going to use logic as to why I should
take the safer path you have to step
into it even if you fail even if it
doesn't work out because you want to
teach yourself that you do difficult
things and so the next time your heart's
going boom boom boom boom boom when an
idea comes from your own head or from
somebody pitching you something if
you're heart's going boom boom boom you
do it it's a sign to
go because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
# believe down in the comments Below on
this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
and if you want to watch Evan's top 10
rules for Success check out the video
next to me I think you can enjoy
continue to believe I will see you there
there's a lot of talk in the Creator
Community now about burnout they know
people one year in on their career and
they're burning out it's like well I've
been doing this for 14 years and haven't
burnt out yet I still love the process
of doing the thing so what is work